Here is that data after outlier removal.
I shifted by subtracting 50 from either dimension.
This goes from 50 to 120 even though it says 0 to 70.
The same is true over here.
Now we can see the guesses are more rational.
They seem to line up a little bit in linear fashion.
They are certainly increasing, which means people who guessed a high weight for me today
as in the vertical axis likely also guessed a high H for me last year.
The guesses aren't entirely random.
What I'm going to ask is how did the guesses this from last year in the horizontal axis
correlate with the guesses from this year.
I'm going to ask you what line best describes this data,
and we're going to compute this using the formulas we learned about in class.
Here is a quick quiz for you.
If you look at that data between axes x and y,
I will assume that you calculate the correlation r,
but for now I want you to look at this and tell me
your best guess of r.
I'll give you a couple of hypotheses— -1, 0.7, 0, +0.7, and +1.
None of those is absolutely correct, but one of them is quite close.
I think you can figure out which one it is.
Please check one of these five boxes--exactly one of those.